- Lamb chop. Lamb chop.
Lamb chop, listen, darling.
I'm in a total kerfuffle.
The delivery for the muffins comes
at 6:00 a.m. honey, not 6:00 p.m.
You're driving me crazy,
and I can't fire you 'cause
I don't have the heart.
One of my first crushes was Darth Vader.
I used to have this
reoccuring dream about him
when I was a kid.
It had definite sexual
undertones. (laughing)
(Ross laughing)
(audience laughing)
- (panting) Just bring it on.
- Yeah.
- Ooh!
(Drew wheezing)
(Drew whooshing)
Yes! Yes!
Maybe.
- Ooh.
- Ah.
(Drew laughing)
- Oh, my heart.
Are you ready, Drew?
- Oh, okay.
- Easy, right? Here.
First time playing.
- Oh, shoot.
- [Ross] No, you're supposed to-
- I suck at this game.
(audience laughing)
- [Ross] Down, down, down!
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
It worked, it worked, it worked!